le mesnil saint denis est ce qu'on
appelle un désert médical aujourd'hui
pour six mille huit cents habitants il
n'y a que deux médecins dont un très
proche de la retraite pour les habitants
c'est une inquiétude des problèmes pour
trouver les médecins et médecins va
partir bientôt la retraite
et du mal à recruter au niveau du minime
si on n'a pas de maison médicale ici je
sais que la plupart des médecins aux
alentours ont déjà une patientèle très
important et beaucoup refusent de
prendre de nouveaux patients donc c'est
vrai que c'est c'est problématique pour
lutter contre le manque de médecins la
commune a décidé d'ouvrir une maison
médicale coût du financement
558 milles euros et pourtant toujours
pas de médecins installés pour le moment
avancée le médecin venait naturellement
remplacé un médecin qui partait
aujourd'hui c'est un peu plus compliqué
il faut pouvoir apporter des structures
telles que la maison médicale pour
qu'ils viennent plus facilement et
surtout qui travaillent en commun
et en collaboration dans cet espace de
120 mètres carrés en plein coeur de la
ville trois cabinets de médecins
généralistes et un cabinet pour une
autre profession médicale un cadre
propice à l'installation de médecins sur
la mairie date de l'inauguration le 25
août prochain